o mesmo após 50 anos esta imagem ainda
nos causam grande Impacto amor viagem
que o homem fez até hoje com destino à
Lua com mais de 384 mil km mostrou que
nós seres humanos podemos protagonizar
frente a qualquer restrição de
resistência e de mercado o que poucos
sabem É que na verdade o homem ao
construir o foguete que fosse a lua ele
utilizou uma tecnologia que é
equivalente hoje eu dou uma calculadora
científica e existe uma restrição muito
forte frente ao processo de construção
do Foguete ou seja toda a construção ela
era feita no estado de Utah bem à
esquerda do mapa e toda a montagem dos
foguetes será feito no cabo canaveral na
Flórida uma viagem de mais de dois mil e
quinhentos quilômetros o que acontecia a
única forma de transportar esses
equipamentos essas peças para
eu era pelo meio de ferrovia só que as
ferrovias elas possuem uma restrição
muito forte que não existia forma de
contornar que era a sua largura de 1,40
pois bem como eu vou vencer a sua
largura de mais de 40 não havia como na
época então tiveram que adaptar o
projeto de foguete que fosse levar o
homem ao espaço para respeitar essa
largura de um metro e quarenta Mas você
já pensou o porquê que existe uma
restrição de um metro e quarenta pensei
que fosse pesquisar rapidamente a gente
teria informação de que as ferrovias
Americanas foram conseguidos pelos
Engenheiros Ingleses esses que foram
responsáveis pelas construções das
carruagens na Europa Mas por que que as
carruagens na Europa tiveram a largura
de um metro e quarenta também porque na
verdade era largura média das ruas da
época então naturalmente fizeram dessa
forma mas você já parou para pensar o
porquê que a largura de um metro e
quarenta das Folhas bem na verdade se a
gente fosse olhar é a largura de dois
traseiros de cavalo puxa vinculado a
outro
e é para que eram as bigas romanas sim
você entendeu bem estamos falando que o
projeto que levou o homem na maior
viagem até hoje teve como restrição a
definição de traseiro de dois cavalos
outro aspecto que é relevante da nossa
sociedade é que todo o processo de
produtivo desde a revolução industrial
ele se baseou no conceito onde as
pessoas não podiam pensar muito
diferente ela tinha que seguir a média
seguir o processo que havia sido
definido elas vão escolher a roupa tem
um trabalhar elas vão escolher um
horário do lanche elas vão escolher um
de que jeito elas fariam aquela
atividade naquele dia ela simplesmente
deveriam Executar a mesma atividade por
anos anos e anos esse mesmo modelo ele
foi para Educação a nossa educação e nem
a Gerais ela segue o mesmo modelo todo
mundo sentado da mesma forma utilizando
dentro do possível a questão de uniforme
até a hora do lanche Você não escolhe a
hora do sinal igual da indústria e o
papel do professor é muito similar ao
papel do supervisor da indústria a
pessoa que fica de pé garantindo que
você
é a média que você tira nota média que
você aprenda na média que você siga a
média bem um aspecto que é super
relevante e a gente espera muito pouco é
por que que a gente algumas vezes aceita
muito bem a mudança outras vezes não vou
dar um exemplo para você imagine que se
você chegasse no seu trabalho na
segunda-feira pela manhã você se
surpreendido com a mudança do seu foco
de atuação você fosse surpreendido por
exemplo com horário que você ia
trabalhar com o nome do seu chefe
qualquer alteração você normalmente não
gosta desse tipo de coisa nós não
gostamos Mas por outro lado quando você
planeja iniciar uma dieta quando você
planeja comprar um carro novo fazer uma
viagem mudar algum comportamento que
você tem você gosta e você até
compartilha com as pessoas com ar de
motivação então Olhem que interessante
quando a mudança vem de fora nós
reagimos de uma era difícil maneira
complicada quando nós decidimos mudar a
gente tem a força e o potencial de fazer
essa forma esse gráfico que eu tô
mostrando para vocês no eixo horizontal
e nos últimos 100 anos desde a revolução
industrial até um pouco depois de
comportamento das pessoas e no eixo
vertical eu trago para vocês o principal
fator que influencia o comportamento da
sociedade e obviamente desde a revolução
industrial comportamento é o que a gente
acabou de falar todo mundo seguindo a
média porque todos modelo é baseado As
instituições era baseado no modelo lento
previsível onde a decisão ela passava
sempre pelas empresas a nova tecnologia
inclusive ela ia primeiro para as
empresas mas de um tempo para cá
Principalmente nos últimos anos a gente
teve uma grande mudança na sociedade o
indivíduo passou a comandar e esse a
mudança fez com que todas as empresas
tiveram que correr o tempo inteiro a
praça adaptar essa grande mudança e o
livro de desconforto deixou de estar com
o indivíduo e passou está com as
empresas a nova tecnologia chega na
nossas mãos Nós criamos os modelos
mentais Nós criamos os comportamentos e
as empresas têm que correr o tempo
inteiro para se adaptar novamente quem a
sei
e vai naufragar nesse novo mercado que
se coloca
um outro aspecto que para mim a super
relevante é a questão de eu não sei se
você sabe mas o cérebro mesmo sendo um
órgão fundamental para o nosso corpo ele
ele tem apenas um percentual muito
pequeno da massa corporal Nossa mas ele
consome quase 25 porcento da nossa
energia diariamente a grande dificuldade
das pessoas é para sair para pensar para
buscar aspectos diferentes é que
necessita de energia do nosso cérebro é
programado para economizar energia logo
ele sempre vai tentar Direcionar para
que tomamos ações dentro do nosso
conforto dentro do que a gente costuma
fazer o que a gente chama de piloto
automático logo tem ideias Inovar mesmo
sendo uma restrição já e das duas
educação nos últimos anos mesmo sendo
uma mudança que nós não gostamos Ainda
temos o aspecto biológico nos complica
mas eu tenho sim como fugir da Média Eu
tenho sim como prosperar Eu tenho sim
como protagonizar E para isso eu vou
trazer algumas pessoas para vocês
conhecerem pessoas essas que não levaram
seu dia a dia como
e amanhã escovando os dentes né onde a
gente entrou no piloto automático todos
nós ninguém parou para planejar como
escovar usei simplesmente escovamos os
dentes e assim nós tomamos ações no
dia-a-dia como aquelas pessoas a imagem
antes da indústria e essas pessoas que
fugiram da Média que são protagonistas
Elas mostram que o protagonismo não está
em fazer simplesmente uma Grande Viagem
à Lua ele está em cada etapa do nosso
dia eu posso ser protagonista na minha
casa na minha família na minha sociedade
no meu bairro que assim por diante o
primeiro caso que eu vou compartilhar
com você sou da Rosa Parks a Rosa Parks
ela foi uma ativista americana que lado
Alabama o caso dela se tornou notório
por que na verdade ela na época existe
uma lei que os brancos tinham
preferência de sentar nos assentos dos
ônibus um absurdo mas é o que existir e
ela se negou a dar lugar a um branco
sentar e ela foi presa isso desencadeou
todo um processo de Protestos nos
Estados Unidos e ela teve o apoio de uma
pessoa que se tornou muito conhecida
nisso depois que é o Martin Luther
eu e ele juntos vencer essa batalha de
injustiça saindo da Média saindo do
pensamento padrão o gilesio que eu tô
mostrando na foto agora aqui para vocês
ele foi o protagonista da sua casa para
o seu filho porque esse ano com a
pandemia ele não tinha condições de
permitir que o seu filho na sua casa eu
tivesse acesso das aulas pela internet
então ele ter que construir uma cabana
perto de um lugar onde tinha sinal quero
que inclusive Tá fazendo aonde eles
trabalhavam e com isso ele foi o
protagonista de permitir que o seu filho
e tem o sonho de ser advogado pudesse
também realizar o seu sonho darão
continuidade às aulas agora pela
internet na barraca que o pai construiu
o azul que na verdade é uma chinesa com
cerca de 50 anos que nasceu muito pobre
pensa em você o seu o seu pai e fica
cego quando você nasce três quatro anos
depois da sua mãe morre uma dificuldade
muito grande ainda você sendo muito
pobre num país aqui há 50 anos chama
condição completamente diferente de hoje
e ela era Operária de fazer vidro para
relógio ela ficava lá lixando vidros o
dia inteiro até que um dia empresa dela
Acabou de ficar dando umas máquinas ela
fez uma cor que comprou a máquina e ela
fora do horário começou a se
especializar fazer serviços adicionais e
hoje ela se tornou a maior profissional
no mundo afora empresa no mundo de
fabricação de telas para celular ela é
hoje a mulher mais rica do mundo não
herdeira e simplesmente com o modelo de
sair da Média ela fazia o melhor quando
por dia ela se dedicava o melhor e por
fim eu vou trazer o caso do Willow musk
Elon musk Sem dúvida alguma é uma pessoa
totalmente fora da Média ele
revolucionou o mercado automobilístico
mercado de energia e o mercado
o esporte ele a energia fóssil e colocou
tudo em cheque Principalmente um dos
modelos mais complexos na nossa
sociedade e que a gente começou a nossa
conversa o modelo de uma Indústria onde
leva o homem ao espaço e ele conseguiu
fazer essa indústria ser muito mais
econômica muito melhor para o meio
ambiente simplesmente Mudando
completamente os paradigmas das
Indústrias fazer com que seus foguetes
inclusive voltassem para a terra depois
dos seus lançamentos Willow musk ele é
uma das pessoas que mais investiram em
meio ambiente até hoje Pense Um
Milionário que quando vendeu para ir
Paula muitos anos atrás podia ter
largado tudo e não ele investiu em
continuar sendo protagonista e sair da
Média E aí veio o grande ponto de agora
ele fez com que novamente nós todos se
emocionasse mas na frente da TV do
celular do computador vendo novamente o
Foguete em do espaço mas agora um
projeto que fazer a parte das pessoas um
projeto privado que fazer com que você
possa entender aqui fazendo uma barraca
ou levando homem no espaço vocês
a fazer todos fugiram da Média fica bem